Lisa what's at the very top of your
education reform list you know right now
ninety-nine point nine percent of the
money is tied up in a public monopoly
where basically you get money for
education no matter what you do so no
matter how many kids fail no matter if
kids come or not you still get money
what are the outcomes I would be better
if in fact the money follow the kids
rather than going to school buildings so
it changes the incentives because kids
have the right of exit and so for
instance take a place like LA Unified
right they now have a hundred and fifty
charter schools that surround LA Unified
and they've lost about twenty five
percent of their kids the last decade
they've lost 150 thousand kids about in
LA Unified know the kids who leave the
system we assume they benefit because
they're choosing to go that's but then
what happens to the kids who are left in
the system you know so basically there's
a couple different things that can
happen I mean theoretically you would
hope that the system would try to
replicate or change their behavior so
kids would stay and in some places that
happens in other places the system
basically implodes so think Detroit
where they hit rock bottom and they have
to do something else what's your
timeline for the Berlin Wall of the
educational an opp aletta to crumble or
be torn down I think we're going to go
along for the next 20 years marginally
making improvements and we'll have some
outliers we're like New Orleans seventy
percent of the kids it's decentralized
but then i think maybe 30 years from now
technology is going to take care a lot
of this is it just becomes so ridiculous
to think of kids having to sit in a
classroom for eight hours a day and
support all of these buildings and
institutions so i'd say in 30 years it's
going to look a lot more decentralized